hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mine your decisions
for thousands of years mathematicians
have been fascinated by the ratio of a
circle's circumference c
to its diameter d
the ancient calculation of this ratio
comes from famous mathematicians whose
names should be known to everyone
this includes archimedes in greece who
estimated 3.14
arya but in india who estimated 3.1416
and li-hue in china who estimated
3.14159
this was a world record calculation not
surpassed for another 1200 years
now what you might find curious is that
these papers do not use the modern day
symbol of pi as we know it to represent
this ratio
this is actually a very recent use of
the symbol pi
it started in 1706 with william jones
and it spread throughout europe and the
rest of the world only in the last 300
years
another interesting thing
is that while the ancient mathematicians
suspected that pi was a never-ending
decimal that didn't repeat
they didn't know it for sure
the first rigorous proof came in 1761
from lambert who demonstrated once and
for all that pi is irrational it cannot
be represented as the ratio of two
positive whole numbers
why did it take so long for this proof
well here's a quote from a textbook when
i was taking an honors math class at
stanford
let me summarize this quote
it essentially says that it is not easy
to prove that pi is irrational
in fact
there's another sentiment in another
textbook i took while i was taking a
math class at stanford
again the textbook states that it is not
simple to prove that pi is irrational so
in this video we're going to attempt
this very task
we're going to rely on a 1947 paper by
the number theorist ivan nevin a simple
proof that pi is irrational but how can
it be simple
we're going to take a little detour to
hemingway
here's a quote
a few things i've found to be true if
you leave out important things or events
that you know about the story is
strengthened
consider the six word story for sale
baby shoes never worn
this is an example of iceberg theory
the words to a story are like the
visible 10 of an iceberg the reader has
to infer the underlying meaning which
strengthens the emotional response to
the story
who exactly is selling the shoes
why are they selling baby shoes
how come they're never worn
once you start to think about these
details the tragedy is made much
stronger than if the author were to tell
you the details
the same sort of idea occurs in
mathematics
niven's proof is just one page long but
each sentence is like the tip of an
iceberg
the proof uses only high school level
calculus but it demands the reader to
work to understand its meaning
this is very common in mathematics where
textbooks have cliches like the proof is
left to the reader
so now let's try and tackle this proof
here's a very high level outline of what
the proof entails
it's a proof by contradiction
first we assume that pi is rational
we then define a function based on the
fraction that pi would be
we then establish properties of the
function
and eventually we discover such a
function has contradictory properties
which then implies pi has to be
irrational
now just to go in a little more detail
first niven defines a family of
functions f x as follows
he then establishes one property that
this integral will always be an integer
then he establishes that this integral
is actually wedged between zero and this
ratio
which will tend to zero as n goes to
infinity
so what does this mean
well property two shows the integral
will be between zero and one for n
sufficiently large and that contradicts
property one that the integral always
has to be an integer and that will be
the contradiction that then leads to the
conclusion pi is irrational
so let's go over a little more detail
we first assume that pi is equal to a
over b for positive integers
we then define a family of functions
depending on a positive integer n as
follows
f of x is equal to x to the power of n
multiplied by a minus b x all raised to
the power of n all over n factorial
now we first need to show property one
that the integral from zero to pi of f
of x times sine of x will always be an
integer
i feel this is the hardest part of the
proof so bear with me the first thing
you're going to have to do is define
another function which is fairly
complicated
g of x is equal to f of x minus the
second derivative
plus the fourth derivative and so on in
the alternating sum of even number
derivatives all the way up to f of 2n
now what's the point of defining this
function
well first we're going to show that f of
x and its derivatives have integer
values at x is equal to zero
this is an iceberg step in niven's proof
there's not much justification and you
have to work out the details
i'm going to present it much like
nimmin's proof
the idea is to notice that n factorial
times f of x is a polynomial with
integer coefficients and its terms in x
range in degree between n and 2n
at x is equal to zero the terms with x
will vanish and terms without x will
work out to integer values due to the
binomial theorem and the power rule of
derivatives now there's a lot going on
in this step but i'm sure you will be
able to work out the details and it'll
be much more satisfying if you do so
the complementary part of this step is
that this result is also true at x is
equal to pi which equals a over b
to see that
verify that f of x is equal to f of a
over b minus x
you can then verify that f of x and all
of its derivatives will have integer
values at x is equal to pi
so what does this get us
we'll now calculate the derivative of
this function
we'll calculate the derivative of g
prime of x times sine of x minus g of x
times cosine of x it's not too
complicated to do this and the result
you get is the second derivative of g
multiplied by sine of x plus g of x
times sine of x
this simplifies to be f of x times sine
of x
so we've now calculated one
anti-derivative of f of x times sine x
so now let's take the integral of f of x
times sine x from zero to pi
we can then evaluate its anti-derivative
from zero to pi
and this simplifies to be g of pi plus g
of zero
now we know this integral always has to
be an integer by step one so we've
established property one
we now need to establish property two
which is this inequality and show that
the right hand side goes to zero as n
goes to infinity
we'll work on this one step at a time
first let's show
that zero is less than f of x times sine
of x in the interval between zero and pi
we do this in two steps
in this interval first notice that sine
is a positive function
and second you have to reason that f x
is a positive function too it's not too
complicated to do that
the product of two positive functions is
positive so that establishes the left
hand side of this inequality
for the right hand side we notice the
following things
first in this interval sine of x is less
than or equal to one
and second we'll be able to reason that
f of x is less than pi to the power of n
times a to the power of n all over n
factorial it's not too complicated to
show that
when you multiply these two inequalities
together you get the right hand side
we'll now integrate each term from zero
to pi
let's evaluate each of these integrals
the left hand side integral is zero
and the right hand side integral will be
pi to the power of n plus one multiplied
by a to the power of n all over n
factorial
we now need to establish that the right
hand side inequality goes to zero
as n goes to infinity so we'll consider
pi times e to the power of pi a
the taylor series of this will be the
following expansion
where each term is pi to the power of n
plus one multiplied by a to the n all
over n factorial since pi times e to the
power of pi a is a convergent series the
terms must tend towards zero
this implies the right hand side will go
to zero as n goes to infinity
so we've now established property one
and property two
so let's put these two together property
two states the integral will be between
zero and one for n sufficiently large
and this contradicts property one that
the integral is always an integer
we therefore can conclude our original
premise was wrong which means pi has to
be irrational
congratulations you've just learned the
proof for one of the most famous results
in mathematics
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
build confidence for students and
inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
out my books listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support